good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining us for the media
availability with ottawa police interim
chief steve bell
joining us are deputy commissioner
chris harkins with the ontario
provincial police
rcmp deputy commissioner mike gm
federal policing
and city of ottawa
general manager emergency and protective
services kim ayotte
press
chef
steve bell
kim ayotte
i'm corporal vladimir napoleon with the
rcmp
i will be the moderator
we will begin with remarks from
internship
interim chief bell
followed by general manager kim ayotte
and then we will proceed to a 15-minute
question period
[Music]
today we're
today we've made some very important
progress in safely removing this
unlawful protest from our streets
at every step in this operation we've
been up front and clear with the
unlawful protesters that they must leave
the area
we've advised them of our enforcement's
efforts so they could continue to make
informed decisions
we've backed up those warnings with a
deliberate and methodical operation
using lawful and safe tactics
the officers on the ground have shown
patience and professionalism
they are well trained and experienced
and they needed all of that expertise to
bring about the results that we are
seeing at every step they faced a
barrage of resistance shoving and
vitriol
we are we all saw that this is the
protesters were aggressive with the
officers and we needed to use horses at
one point
as a result we responded this morning by
adding helmets and batons to our
equipment for the safety of our officers
when we deployed our officers this
morning you saw the public order units
on the ground sweeping across the
downtown core from east to west and
moving demonstrators out of the
parliamentary precinct
our officers continued to face
resistance
at one point a flare was ignited by a
protester officers used a chemical
irritant also known as pepper spray to
disperse unlawful demonstrators who were
resisting police orders
sadly we again saw young children being
brought to the unlawful demonstration
and to the front of our police operation
this is dangerous and is putting young
children at risk
so far today we've arrested 47 people
that brings the total so far to 170.
as we continue to take back our streets
our streets city of ottawa crews and
other municipal vehicles came into the
area to clean up and tow away all of the
demonstrators possessions and vehicles
this is tough work
these officers are doing what they've
been trained to do they have
demonstrated unparalleled discipline
restraint and the utmost professionalism
i commend them for their actions
yesterday and throughout the day today
i'm proud of them and all the members of
our police service that have contributed
to this operation
justification
service and natural community pandon set
period difficile
this is an ottawa-led police joint
operation but this is actually a
canadian effort
we have officers from across the
province and country here to help us
every person supporting this effort is
proud to be here
police have a vital role in our
democracy and this operation shows our
institutions commitment and ability to
maintain a lawful society
but we could do not do this without the
support of the community that we serve
all levels of government the federal
provincial and municipal have
contributed to this effort all to
support our city and every other
community being affected by similar
unlawful demonstrations
by working together we are showing the
strength of our democracy
to downtown residents we are focused on
your safety
we are not going anywhere until you have
your streets back
we are prepared we are aware of
protesters leaving the parliamentary
precinct moving to surrounding
neighborhoods we are working with our
partners and we will remove these
protesters peacefully from your area
this operation is still moving forward
it is not over and it will takes takes
up more time until we have achieved our
goals
uh following uh mission comments i'll be
available to answer questions
thank you chief bill
good afternoon everyone
the city continues to support our police
service who made excellent progress
towards ending this occupation
i want to thank the police leadership
and every single police officer from the
many different forces who are involved
in this operation
you are doing great work
i also want to thank and recognize city
staff who've been working day and night
over the past few weeks under
challenging conditions
whether you're working in public safety
emergency management in the eoc or in
the ncrcc whether you're public works
social services media relations
or working for or in a city facility
whether your corporate security or
behind the scenes in a support capacity
i want to thank you
i specifically want to thank our bylaw
officers who've issued over 3 600
tickets
and our fire services firefighters and
paramedics who are working in the red
zone as part of an integrated an
integration team directly with police
special teams
or responding to regular calls within
the red zone
to the city leadership team thank you
for your constant support and
availability during these difficult
times
you have been strong during this very
difficult and unprecedented event
please know that the city is always
supporting activities is already
supporting activities aimed at restoring
the downtown neighborhoods to their
normal state
this includes removing debris garbage
vehicles clearing snow installing fences
and repairing any damage left behind by
these protesters
thank you and merci
i will now invite each media agency to
come to the microphone to ask a question
please ask one question each
starting with your starting with your
name and the media that you represent
[Music]
represented
ctv national news
thanks for taking our questions
can you say when will residents have
their streets back do you have a day in
mind as wellington is now cleared out
so we've been
we've been clear from the beginning this
is this is an extremely large complex
operation
you all understand that because you've
been so actively covering and reporting
on on it since it's begun
we we won't commit to any end time
because the the progress of it needs to
be measured needs to be methodical needs
to be safe and lawful as we've indicated
all the way through that is how we've
approached this protest since we've
started that is how we will approach it
until it's completed
i cannot overstate we are in this until
it is over every one of our police
agency partners has indicated their
continued and ongoing support to work
with us to finish this unlawful
occupation you have our commitment that
we are here until the very end if i had
a choice it would be right now
and that's why i implore all the
protesters who remain there go home this
occupation is now over we will continue
with our mission until it is complete
and can you explain the chemical
irritant that was used against the
protesters by police today what kind of
chemical uh was it and and why was it
used and and you also uh
my other question here that i really
need that that's important that i want
to squeeze in here is
you talk about the professionalism of
police but with respect sir can you
explain what appears to be excessive
force by police officers when a
protester is arrested there is multiple
videos on social media showing police
delivering blows with their knee and
their fists while the protesters are
down is this necessary
so i i haven't specifically seen the
videos you're talking about but what i
cannot advise you is we do have
mechanisms to review all of the arrests
we will absolutely be involved in
reviewing arrests to make sure that the
lawful amount of force was used as we
executed our mission
we've been very clear from the beginning
as this has escalated and as protesters
have not heeded the the urging the
warnings and then the direction to leave
our streets that we would need to
escalate in our tactics that is what
you're seeing us engaged in to
ultimately remove people who are
refusing to leave
so we see that you guys with the help of
your other agencies have practically
gained all of wellington where
parliament hill is located so can you
tell us what's the next step into the
operation and are are the forces
starting to stretch thin as as you gain
terrain you're going to need more people
so what's the next step in the operation
and maybe how we're doing with officers
so what you've seen and we indicated
from the very beginning days this has
been going to be a very deliberate and
methodical approach to how we're going
to remove how we're going to gain back
the area and remove everyone to execute
the plan we have we also indicated that
we have the resources we need to execute
this plan what you've seen over the past
number of days is the execution of that
plan with the resources that we need to
finalize it we are approaching areas our
members are taking control of areas and
then we're bringing crews behind us to
remove vehicles remediate any of the
conditions that the protesters any of
the damage the protesters may have done
to make sure that as our citizens get
their streets back they are the streets
that they had before this started we
will continue with our plan we'll
continue to move ahead and i can tell
you it is to this point going exactly as
we had anticipated
um
have the police say
fire harm since the beginning of this
major policy intervention
so what i can tell you is that we have
several criminal investigations ongoing
that relate to the seizure of weapons i
don't have specific
specifics on any of those investigations
because they're not yet complete and
there is no charges resulting from them
when we do have that we will provide
that information
hi ashley burke cbc national news um can
you tell us what other methods that you
use today to try and disperse crowds
that we didn't see yesterday it sounded
like there was other sort of sonic or
you know other sort of sound things that
were done today that hadn't been the
past and what else
yeah we've been pretty clear from the
beginning we're actually not going to
discuss the tactics we use
one of the things that you've seen that
we've been engaged in is we we were
monitoring we've learned from previous
protests and demonstrations we're
monitoring the coverage
one of the tactics that the protesters
and demonstrators are using is
misinformation uh information that is
inaccurate uh information that misleads
the public
we're actively tweeting and providing
information out in through social media
and other media
mechanisms in order to be able to try
and get accurate factual information
around what is going on within the
protest without actually
divulging any police tactics
and just speaking of conflicting reports
yesterday there were a lot of them when
it came to the the case where the police
horse entered the crowd um ottawa police
had said that a bicycle was thrown at
the feet of a horse
but there are conflicting reports online
about that can you specifically tell us
what happened and what happened to the
civilian and the horse
so thank you um that when you talk about
him misinformation that's specifically
one of the one of the demonstrations for
us of that um
what what happened is the the crowd was
escalating around the police there was
tension that was continuing to escalate
between our public order unit members
and the demonstrators on the line that
was
resulting in increased aggression by the
demonstrators
members of the public over mounted
public order unit rode through the crowd
that created separation and lowered the
temperature and um and circumstances
that existed there so as not to escalate
force
almost immediately there was
tweets there was pictures that had been
photoshopped out
on social media that indicated uh people
had died as a result of that we the
horses had run over
somebody with a walker in the crowd what
i can indicate is there was two members
of the protesters who did collide with
the horses they fell down they
immediately got back up and started to
again engage in in their protest and
demonstration activity that is one of
the circumstances where we as we monitor
we're identifying this information and
as quickly as we can providing accurate
real information about what is occurring
on the ground
sorry but was a bike actually thrown at
a horse because there are images online
that might maybe perhaps it was someone
else's uh electronic wheelchair
so we'll we'll have to get more specific
information on that for you and i'll be
able to provide more in coming days
um hi chief phil it's juan canelo from
cbc ottawa local um you say you've
arrested about 170 people since the
police action has begun how many folks
have you actually charged
so we're continuing to uh
one step is the arrest the next step is
the pro processing and charging of those
individuals we haven't yet
pulled together and identified the
number of charges that we've laid but
that will be
released to the media and to the public
as soon as it's available but are people
being let go for example without being
charged with anything say if they
promise to go home
so what i can indicate again is we've
arrested 170 people we'll continue to do
the investigations and as we've
identified those that are charged and
those that may be released
unconditionally those numbers will
provide them to the media and as this is
a massive operation any chance there's a
price tag on this yet i think earlier on
when we had asked for 1800 officers
there was an indication it might cost
2.5 million dollars a day
is that accurate or i know it's probably
not exact at this moment so it's uh it's
something that's very important to us we
know that this is going to be an
extremely expensive operation uh we've
already talked to our federal and
provincial partners about
how at the end of the day we we will
look at
having money provided to the police
service for that those uh discussions
are ongoing we continue to track our
costs we our partners continue to work
with us to identify the costs of
policing to actually manage this event
and at the culmination of it we'll be
able to provide accurate figures you
don't have a tally up until now for
example just to remind our journalists
one question thank you
hi chief bill gabriel i'm from the
french radio of cbc just wondering do
you know how many buildings are in
lockdown
right now in ottawa and
i will take a response in french also
please
so we we don't identify buildings to go
into lockdown we don't tell building
owners to put their buildings in
lockdown we do provide public safety
announcements as to where
the
the
demonstration is happening where our
police operations are occurring within
the demonstration so we don't directly
control the number of buildings which
are locked down so i don't have that
number for you
sorry
hi there uh erika ibrahim the canadian
press um
i'm wondering uh what your message is to
protesters and canadians more broadly
who might be upset and angry with uh
images uh being published of police
hitting protesters with batons and other
types of force
there are images of some people um there
are some police striking crowd members
with batons
who were retreating and not being
aggressive toward them there were media
in the crowds that that have witnessed
and reported on this i'm wondering what
you would say to um to those who may be
concerned by that
as i indicated earlier we will have the
opportunity to review all of those files
there are complaint mechanisms for
people to enter into if they feel that
there is excessive use of force
by members of our police service
what i will also say is
we have been here for three weeks i have
been at this podium for the last five
days imploring people to leave
asking them to get out of our streets
this occupation is over we have advised
them that if they peacefully leave they
may go home that still exists
we also indicated that we would escalate
and forcefully remove people from the
streets if they did not comply some of
that is what you're seeing so i will
stand here today again and say this
demonstration is over go home if you
don't go home we will remove you from
the streets
this will be the last question
hello i'm andy liam uh from independent
media so i was in the crowd yesterday um
i was unfortunately hit with some pepper
spray i just have a question uh
there's some video cameras that the
police are using and some news outlets
that reporting that you're gathering
intelligence with those cameras
can you elaborate like if the protesters
at this point
uh you know uh retreat and go home
uh are they gonna be getting sort of
repercussions down the road are you
going to be sort of actively pursuing
the people that you've been sort of
documenting and filming who are still
out there protesting what are your plans
after this after the protest is over
thank you it's a great question and the
simple answer is yes
if you are involved in this protest we
will actively look to identify you and
follow up with financial sanctions and
criminal charges absolutely
this investigation will go on for months
to come it has many many different
streams both from a federal
financial level from a provincial
licensing level from a criminal code
level from a municipal breach of court
order breach of court and junction level
it will be a complicated and
time-consuming
investigation that will go on for a
period of time
you have my commitment that that
investigation will continue and we will
hold people accountable for taking our
streets over
and could i just ask one more question
this concludes the
media availability
[ __ ] concluded point please
um
[Music]
you